very exciting night if you're a fan of
the toronto blue jays one of the best
pitching prospects in baseball will make
his major league debut tonight in
washington in what is technically the
blue jays home opener tonight at
nationals park that's why you see the
white jerseys nate pearson will take a
major league mound in a regular season
game for the first time buck there are
going to be a lot of eyes on him tonight
another good breaking ball and he
strikes out the first battery faces in
the big leagues
and you can see right down the middle
but it had enough of a downward tilt
that turner can't make contact you hear
so much about that big arm with the
fastball and that was a very well thrown
slider yeah the the god-given ability he
has allows him to throw the fastball but
he is not just a thrower he has worked
extremely hard
here's the numbers on max last year he
want the averages against on the
fastball 216 on the slider 167 to change
up 238
2-2
swing and a miss so we have the 28th
overall pick in 2017 on the mound and
the 28th overall pick in 2016
at the plate
got him blew it by him in 96
and a three up three down second inning
for nate pearson
he's one for seven in his rookie
campaign is making his second start in
place of the injured bo buchet
the o2 swinging a miss he's out on three
pitches scherzer puts him away with the
slider for his third strikeout and it's
weird not to hear the cheering crowd
had him all locked up on o2
really taking all the starch out of a
power hitter swing there fact that they
have to honor that and then the slider
becomes more effective
and he got him 99 at the knees to freeze
them
and pierson gets out of it bottom of the
fourth guerrero tolez and jensen
3-2 in there and for max scherzer number
five max is looking for his first one
two three inning he fires swinging a
miss blew it by him 95 second time
jensen strikes out and max has six k's
through four nate pearson with four
shutout innings thus far
and he went around to the breaking ball
one down here in the fifth
three two and he got him took a little
bit more off the breaking ball and did
you see just a little hint of a fist
pump there by pierson near his hip
nothing too big but he was fired up
about putting away robles
taking the page out of max scherzer's
book a 3-2 slider for a strikeout he
struck out three
scherzer
delivers swing foul tip held by suzuki
and
espinal is gone again
on three pitches max with his seventh
strikeout
has been an overmatch two at bats two
three pitch strikeouts
here comes
oh my
drops right at the knees eight k's
so max now has 19 strikeouts in just
over 10 innings this year charlie
montoya going over to talk to nate
pearson
and we can't see you know if charlie's
smiling but i think we yeah we can't
yeah his eyes are all wrinkled up
absolutely
nate pearson is the third pitcher in
blue jays history to throw five plus
scoreless innings in a major league
debut joining moro gaza when trent
thornton thornton of course did it last
year against the tigers
nothing nothing top of the seventh big
pitch here coming from sam gavilio and
it's swung on and hit on a line into the
left back goes guriel reaching out makes
the catch as he tumbles to the ground
lourdes goriel jr with a great catch
at the very limits of his reach as he
went back over his head
keeps this a nothing nothing game as the
runners have to retreat
that's a tremendous catch by the blue
jay left fielder and
i think we said this as the season was
approaching when's the last time you
thought about lourdes gorilla jr being
on the diamond jordan romano trying to
hold up his end of the bargain here
inheriting
a two on two ounce situation at the
bottom of the seventh inning
2-2 and he got him with a 99 mile an
hour fastball
huge pitch coming in this game it's been
a well-played contest
three hits aside no runs first and third
one out hebrew a couple of steps wide of
the bag at third hudson kicks delivers
swinging a hard ground ball diving stop
turner flips to second for one throw to
first it's a double play
a spectacular double play for the
nationals to get out of the inning with
the infield drawn in a diving stop by
turner to his left able to get to his
knees and flip it to cash showing the
ball hit so hard plenty of time to turn
an inning ending 6-4-3 double play
nationals with the bases loaded no outs
strike out back-to-back and now need a
clutch two out hit from adam eaton up
the middle
off the pitcher a play at second
safe is the call
hunter wendell's dead
calling stevenson safe
and the nets are on top
great hustle by andrew stevenson was he
safe we got to see this again before i
get real excited i don't think headsets
are coming off what do we got
runner's safe in the next lead so here's
cabrera bases remain loaded left-handed
batting switch hitter against the
right-hander 3-1
swinging a hard ground ball to first
gets by guerrero down the line this may
clear the bases it's headed along the
sidewall toward the corner kibum scores
stevenson to the plate eaton will score
cabrera headed for third he'll make it
without a play as he slides in and the
nationals have broken it open with three
runs home it's the nationals four and
the blue jays nothing here in the tenth
inning
that ball to guerrero's glove side he
couldn't handle it that was a shot
he got it by him and then
uh the good fortune of missing the
sidewall and then hugging all the way
down into the corner to clear the bases
and as drupal cabrera
chugging around to third
in the air
kind of in no man's land out there in
rushing in his row blaze and the nats
win it